excellent you know good good evening I
guess yes sure where you're located
you're in the UK where are you
yes I'm currently in England uh-huh I'm
talking today the Lina Vasquez who is
another many internet polyglots and I'm
very intrigued by her background and
it's sometimes watching her videos and I
watch your videos in different languages
it's hard to tell what her native
language is so maybe really you could
even use your yes you could introduce
yourself and then tell us what your
native languages mm-hmm well actually
before I start what do you think is my
native language I don't want to give it
away yet well I don't know I don't know
I mean your name is Spanish you sound
very English I have no idea
interesting interesting say yes my name
is Lena Vasquez and maybe you're asking
go ahead
yeah sorry what did you want to say well
you know what we all wait we what we'll
save that but now I will tell you later
on what I think your native languages
but tell us a little bit about your
interest in languages how you came to be
interested in languages and you have a
bit of a presence on the internet and so
far the mountains all of that developed
interesting question I think for me it
just boils down to the fact that I've
always been ever since I was a child
just really curious about the world and
my mom and I would travel a lot between
I'm not gonna give it away yet so I
travel between Europe and Australia so
yes I speak English
well because I would I would hope I
speak it well but I grew up in Australia
and did all my schooling there and I
think having kind of almost lived in
airports I always say as a child it
really exposed me to a lot of different
cultures from a very young age
so I remember there's a particular story
where I was at one of those McDonald's
Polly kind of playgrounds I guess at the
airport in Russia and there was a there
was a young boy who kept throwing those
you know balls from the ball pit at me
and I said stuck to him in in the two
languages that I knew and none of them
worked and I went to my mom and I said
mom like mom he's not he's not
responding
and my mum picked up that he was Russian
and she taught me the Russian word for
stuff which is what it's there like just
a stop and a word and I think that was
one of the key experiences in my life
that really resonated with me and I
realized that languages really gift you
always the superpower and with I guess
through my life as well it's just become
more and more relevant and more apparent
that you really do see the world in a
different like through a different lens
when you speak a different language and
you build just stronger connections to
people as well and yes so I guess I do
have an internet presence you could say
I have a youtube channel or two actually
and my primary one is is really just
about I think exposing people to the
joys and the lifestyle that speaking
many different languages and learning
many different languages because we're
always learning yeah that they provides
you with and the other channel is a
German channel which is called double
dutch and my business partner and I we
teach people German through kind of
comical videos and like little skits and
other than that I also study
psychotherapy so another big love of
mine is his psychology and psychotherapy
and linguistics so I think just that
genuine interest in people and human
nature has led me to learning all of
these different languages so in a
nutshell you know we are
we will put links to your various sites
in the description box so the people can
go there and get to know you better
one of the questions one of the things
that I sometimes think about is you know
the idea of speaking foreign language is
very attractive the idea of being able
to say something to avoid an airport in
Russia yeah whatever it might be you
know you're in the souk in Fez Morocco
and you can actually communicate all of
this is very attractive and I agree with
you that it gives you a sense of power
but it is also a lot of work a lot of
work you have to put in the time it's
not necessarily difficult work but it's
it requires a lot of time and times you
have to keep on reminding yourself of
the rewards because at times it seems
like an effort you're so how do you deal
with this issue how do you keep yourself
going on tasks
well I'll step back which languages do
you speak which languages are you
interested in learning mmm oh well I
feel like I would say I would I would
love to learn every single language but
right I speak so I speak English German
Spanish French Latvian Portuguese
Italian and Russian all to various
degrees and I've learned a couple of
languages that I would really like to
get back into so I kind of started
studying ones like Swedish and Japanese
I recently touched on Korean so I think
Korean is gonna be my next language so
how do I keep myself going to be honest
I think there are many different phases
and sometimes I feel like it has a it's
a very complex question because a for
each individual is going to be very
different but for me I think I've tried
my best to build a life around languages
so if there's one thing I was always
certain about it was I want languages
and different
then speaking different languages to be
an integral part of what I do so I think
habits are very important so I try and
like have different habits that I build
up for different languages so for
example I love reading and I always make
sure that at least once a week I read
something in the different thing which
is particularly the ones that I am
fluent in so that it doesn't drop a
level if you know what I mean if we
speak in levels but um I think to be
very honest with you I also go through
phases like at different times of my
life for example when I studied at
University and I studied languages they
were part of my life every single day
and then obviously coming out of an
educational scenario you yourself kind
of have to take the initiative to
implement or keep those languages going
so I also have or recently got in a
teacher for Russian and Portuguese
because I realized okay as much as I
love to think of myself as a superwoman
you do need that kind of external push
to in anything really to keep you
growing as a as a person and in your
skill set mm-hmm okay no it's it's
interesting because I struggle with it
right now I've assigned myself the
difficult task whether I think I have a
hint as to what your native languages
but I'll say that very long okay but so
right now I've decided you know I'm
gonna learn three languages at the same
time and and I'm gonna do them every day
so that's person Arabic and Turkish
mm-hmm so there are days when geez you
know and and of course when you're doing
three in there and I'm not sure it was a
wise thing to do I decided to do it why
not
yeah I'm reluctant to give in and say
you know because it's so much slower
through during three a day you're not
easy making that much progress than any
one of them although there are times
like this morning I was listing the fire
scene I thought I heard
a lot better clearer more clearly than
over before so there is to some extent
the idea of putting three languages at
once makes you a little more observant
you know you notice things a little
better but of course you aren't learning
us quickly so I'm sometimes a little
discouraged and then of course I can't
stop because I've told everyone I'm
gonna do this I can't wait you know but
of course ultimately to be able to
understand these languages is
tremendously you know attractive so I I
agree with you you have to get some
habits so one of the things I've said is
I have to like onlain to have to create
a density in each language so that's
automatically it's a stupid task it's
like taking out the garbage once a week
yeah I just have to be it well that's
the thing so you have these tasks yeah
no sorry I didn't want to interrupt but
I think that's a really key point is a
lot of people I think they have a bit of
a false idea as to what like motivation
is so I think there's this misconception
that public lots are always motivated
why not darrell-icious it's one of those
things I think for me it comes a lot of
it's maybe a little bit of an ego thing
to be honest where I don't want to ever
fail in something especially when I know
well I want to just always do my best in
something and I might take a break for
example there was a there was a phase I
had for French and other languages at
times where I was so sick of it and just
this is where me studying two languages
at once also comes in I love doing - you
want two languages at once because when
one gets a bit too much when one gets a
bit too much I just I have the other one
to kind of compensate with so you never
really get raw it but the initial point
was yet people think that you're always
motivated and you're not and that's okay
so it is sometimes you know eat as much
as I think we can say we love languages
and we love the process of learning it
just sucks sometimes it's just arduous
and sometimes you're doing I remember
when I was learning particularly for
German certain grammar concepts and it
just felt like I had put in so much work
and I wasn't seeing any results but I
still just kept doing the work because I
knew
at some point it has to get easier it's
gonna be easier I mean I think this is
true and and that's one of the reasons
why I don't spend a lot of time trying
to learn no thanks my ability to I mean
I can read it just to be aware of what's
there and then I read it again to
refresh my memory but I know that I'm
not gonna master those concepts until
that a lot of exposure yeah a lot of use
of the language whereas acquiring words
you know that's something that's
relatively easier I cannot watch my
wires here my microphone so I focus on
increasing my look at increasing my
comprehension and it it's not
perceptible and yet
after a couple of months you go back to
material you looked at two months
earlier and of course don't understand
so much more yes if you have more words
so that does increase like the more time
you put in the more words you require
and the more familiar you become with
the language that is not so true of
trying to remember case endings in
German you can keep on looking at them
or languages actually at the minute and
you might get them you might have a
conversation and I'm hitting my case
endings and my verbs of motion in
Russian I think I'm doing really well
and then a week later I have another
conversation and I just yeah that's a
slow process I think it's exactly I
think there's always no matter what you
learn I think there is always a more
effective way to learn it that works for
you as an individual and just in general
so face endings are a great example I'm
also not the biggest fan of grammar so
with German I I did German Studies at
university so obviously I went through
you know four years of essay writing and
everything in grandma you know a lot of
things that you would never use but I
think the biggest thing is as well when
when you don't have an actual when you
don't have that element of of relevance
to you and your life you can have the
best table given to you the best you
know color-coordinated explanations but
if it doesn't just click within your
mind you're never going to learn it
because you're not learning how to use
it I think at the end of the day you
know we we learn language to reproduce
it and to speak it so I mean not always
but primarily yeah we do well I I don't
think you have to I think the advantage
of focusing on comprehension is that not
being able to nail the case endings
doesn't really bother your comprehension
right because there's so much redundancy
in the words you can figure out what's
going on who's doing what to whom but
when you go to speak of course now
there's more of a requirement to get the
case right not because the other person
won't understand you but it's it's kind
of like your shirttail hanging out like
you're exposed yes yes weakness and
errors which we don't like to do that
because my vein yeah yeah but you know
what we can talk I think for an hour or
two and we are gonna have another
discussion for your channel so I thought
I should wrap this up and I'll tell you
a a city that I once visited which I
really enjoyed where people speak two
languages I wonder if you have visited
it Riga yeah I think I've been there a
couple of times it's a lovely City
lovely old town very friendly people and
of course it's completely bilingual yeah
or at least let's play this way it's not
fighting or like mantra it's like it's
bilingual everyone speaks and I would
say everyone but a lot of people speak
Russian half the population is native
speakers of Russian but there's no
evidence of Russian this kind of air
brushed out of the of the witches I you
know and I have some sympathy for that
because they did the same in Montreal my
guy who are up in a name is speaking
part of Montreal all the shops were
early English everything was in English
and now if you go there all the shops
are in French even though the people are
still largely english-speaking so
typically you have a situation where a
previous sort of language injustice
creates a reaction
and the erection sometimes also has some
elements of injustice and that was the
case in Quebec but but probably in the
long run a good thing at least in the
case of Quebec in other words when I was
young in Montreal if you wanted a good
job yet speak English even if you were
practical and now people can work in
French so in the so called in you know
somewhat unjust language laws in fact
have re-established French as the
dominant language in Quebec you know at
all levels at all levels and I think
that was a good thing and I think some
of the same applies perhaps in Latvia I
don't want to get it well it's
interesting you say that uhm because
well yes sir Latvian was my first
language but and I was born in Riga but
it's an interesting concept for me
because I actually I spent the first
seven years of my life traveling between
Latvia and Australia so I was exposed to
English basically from the age of 10
months and so I grew up bilingual but
not with Russian it was quite a funny
story because my mother and my
grandmother would speak Russian amongst
themselves in order for me not to
understand something and I could almost
I obviously like I learned the alphabet
when I was quite young the Russian
alphabet but I actually learned to
Russian through my own kind of incentive
in the sense of I remember it was a
little bit I know I just said to my mum
always one day I'm gonna be able to
speak Russian and understand everything
you're saying anything that was my
motivation but you're very right when I
recently went back to well I say
recently two years ago but when I went
back to Latvia the last time and it was
with my ex-boyfriend who was Russian
he spoke more I think then I did because
there were there is a huge Russian
population and a lot of people don't
want to learn Latvian and yes as you
said we're not getting into politics but
it's definitely yeah and interesting
interesting concepts to discuss well
that's right and and of course the
problem in Latvia I like you know those
language issues every
yes Ukraine Belgium Catalunya yeah your
name but bad you know ever ever but the
one thing that's unique about Latvia or
the Baltic States in general is that the
total number of speakers of those
languages is so small mmm exactly so um
so you can say French okay but there's
this large french-speaking community in
the world even Ukrainian there's like
you know and the amazing thing in
Ukraine is everybody speaks both like
totally comfortably without hesitation
they can switch from A to B B Bay yeah
not the case in Quebec but but Estonia
Latvia Lithuania there's very few
speakers of those languages that's true
and so therefore I am I have great
sympathy and there's no shortage of
Russian speakers there's no shortage yes
your major presence cultural and
whatever historically and and anyway you
want to name it Russia's a big a big
language in the world
yeah so I have sympathy for the lab pins
and the Athenians and historians or for
that matter the québécois who are doing
things to maintain their position as a
sort of a minority yeah and that means
that sometimes they do things that may
be perceived as not entirely fair to the
majority cuz I still support them I mean
that's my position anyway yeah no I
understand it I mean at the end of the
day I think people forget that Latvia
has I think a population of 1.8 million
that's exactly like the city I grew up
in in Australia has more than that so
it's and of course there are Latvian
zones and how many are native Latin that
means B well exactly so we are a small
bunch we're a mighty Bunch
but good all right well on that note so
I think I figured out perhaps what your
native language is perhaps it's a
mixture of English and Latvia and so I
can end it here and then we're gonna
continue on your exactly so it was a
pleasure
okay so thank you for coming to visit
well it's lovely to be here and now
we're going to see each other
[Music]